political unrest in Hong Kong has
prompted China to speed up its vast
Regional Development Program the greater
Bay Area project Beijing has long
planned this but believes the promise of
strong economic growth will ease anger
in Hong Kong which will lose its special
status in 28 years so the government
wants to make Hong Kong a key part of a
cluster of cities in the Pearl River
Delta creating a vibrant economic area
Chinese President Xi Jinping describes
the greater bay project is central to
China's great national rejuvenation Hong
Kong is just a part of a greater plan
there let's have a closer look at this
greater Bay Area the scheme would see 12
cities in the area linked up to form an
integrated economic hub those would
include Shenzhen Macau and Guangzhou
further in the north the greater Bay
Area has a population of 70 million and
a GDP of well over 1.5 trillion US
dollars making it a potential rival to
places like San Francisco New York or
Tokyo already a major investment hub
Hong Kong would be the project's crown
jewel the greater Bay Area already
accounts for 12% of China's GDP China
also wants to develop a world-class
Airport cluster in the greater Bay Area
air freight traffic is already greater
than the figures for San Francisco New
York and Tokyo combined and then they're
shipping three of the world's top ten
container ports are in that area experts
see the plan as part of China strategy
to catch up with America let's talk
about this with our resident China
watcher Clifford Coonan who joins me in
the studio hi Clifford
what exactly are the Chinese planning
there and why well this is a massive
development plan I mean to give you an
idea of the scale you've got cities like
Macau which we're in the gambling it was
more gambling than Las Vegas
you got Guangzhou which is used to be
known as count on the trading capital of
the world and then in the Middle Ages
you've got Hong Kong of course which is
the freest city in the freest economy in
the world so you've got all these
incredible cities there that there
to bring together a powerhouse each and
every one of them in itself exactly and
you know on their own they're big
together they're massive and you know
the China wants to get as much of this
energy this sort of the resources and
coordinate all of these and wants all of
that but then again as we know there are
problems with Hong Kong yeah it's true
so watch out rest of the world but it's
this an attempt to also an attempt to
bring Hong Kong in line to fully pull it
into China way ahead of this 28 year
deadline that is looming that's right I
think it is I mean as you say in 2047
the basic law ceases to exist and we
don't really know what's gonna happen
there the basic law defines the
relationship like a mini Constitution
that Hong Kong has under the terms of
the handover for 1997 so at that time
Hong Kong status will change and what
China wants to do is to make it part of
this coordinated hub this Pearl River
Delta this this project and through that
obviously the integration will work in
Hong Kong's favor but it will also kind
of make Hong Kong just another city in
the region so it has a double effect for
the Chinese government in terms of
bringing an end to instability in the
region most people don't realize that
there is intense competition between
these cities that we've mentioned in
that area right that's right I mean as
we were saying earlier no they all in
existed independently for so long and
they were such made they're such major
cities in their own rights a Schengen of
course is a great example shin gen was a
tiny fishing village four decades ago
and now a believable route I know I mean
the scale of development there you know
you go out in Shenzhen to places that
didn't just didn't exist ten years ago
you know it's a constantly evolving City
so you have this incredible city
shenzhen for example which the Chinese
government is now really pushing it's
got special tax rates for a tech and
innovation lower than Hong Kong which is
at 15% already very low is that
alternative tech companies out of Hong
Kong and it's more to bring talent in
for one thing that's a big thing that
Hong Kong is still good at attracting
Hong Kong still has the framework and
the legal framework the technology you
know the investment framework which
China's still struggling with because
it's a it doesn't have the same freedoms
as Hong Kong
so maybe it's hoping that a little bit
of that rub off but it's also buy to
encourage competition I think between
Hong Kong and Shenzhen and that will
hopefully bring Sheng Jian up to Hong
Kong's level I think as as the as the
project develops politically do you
think people in Hong Kong need to be
worried by this tendency or is this
purely economic and sort of just part of
a normal development and I think they
are worried about it and for for the
past four forty years Hong Kongers have
been investing a crazy in southern China
so a lot of the factories are already
owned by Hong Kong companies and they've
got a lot of presence there and you know
when you drive in change and everyone
has to license plates they have this
change and license plate and they have
the Hong Kong license plate so they're
very integrated already but people are
aware of the fact that there's different
rules that play in Shenzhen so I think
they want to they're definitely keeping
an eye on how things develop politically
because they do treasure the freedoms
that they have in Hong Kong and even
just in investment terms clipper kunnen
thank you very much